welcome to this video playing cupid 11
there ok got the rest of opening this is
getting popular I don't know why exactly
but it gets it gets more popular well
this color the way he's playing it it
looks kind of strange i have to say but
just looks like black should be quite
fine there with this with the center
then point do you mean no before ok so
the idea is to just weaken everything
every square every porn that you have
right like c2 c4 and and so on that's
the point ok let's see how to exploit
that you might have before and the long
diagonal hmm you for might be if he gets
that and it would be would be helping
him quite a bit John I should get the
Queen somewhere somewhere our town hmm I
wonder if he fires and let's do a five
and force him to do that in 1975 would
be nice he might have before but i think
i can take it should be okay efore takes
should be good and if it's not playing
it now I'm homely managing to prevent it
with 90 75
yeah I only have to make sure that
nothing tactical happens here because
strategically speaking wide is pretty
much toast c2 is weak and the whole see
file is completely completely bad and
the queenside bonds be 5 a-3 are
potentially week will be very difficult
for him now he's thinking as usual they
win their position quickly and then
start to think somehow this is a common
mo okay so one that was the idea anyway
now i also have 95 °c for with the
temple he might play and form no okay
let's do that Knight to c4 cannot be bad
only mean maybe I have something better
but Knight to c4 should be good don't
see how he place then probably has to
play Bishop back to see one
yeah queen e chua stuff only move anyway
white resigns no he resigns yeah well
okay the position is very bad but ok
this this and yes to play Bishop see one
then probably just just this kind of
position it's it's very difficult for
him to move them I can try to expand in
the center in further yeah sorry for the
somewhat unfriendly remarks earlier but
this is just just really really bad in
many moves that I don't really
understand like h3y exactly and I can't
hear like a three okay well if you now
start to play normally yeah maybe I know
take on c5 play for okay but before
before completely kills kills yourself
strategically yeah with the sea fowl
permanently weekend I actually think
that I played it played it badly this is
this is maybe not the best I should go
here to have 95 quickly that that's
probably better yeah I mean this I'm not
sure yeah even that is good I get this
in there is no tactic be to assess
hanging yeah this is excellent that's an
excellent pollution whole black it's
even better than then the actual game
yeah maybe if he has some kind of this
this might be an idea it looks strange
but looks at the squares where the night
might come in like here and see for
maybe yeah this looks this looks
playable and this may be a way to punish
me for not playing Bishop d 695 yeah
it's playable why does not substantially
worse in this position computer gives
equal down yeah but here after 94 was I
actually took time on that leg move but
here camp it's very difficult i'm going
having this and this to see for so of
course also Knight b6 to see for so that
gets very difficult I don't see how he
gets rid of its LightSquared weaknesses
or the weaknesses on the C file it's
probably i don't i don't think you can
save this position against could play
probably not possible okay well thanks
for watching